My involvement in the project goes back to
the actual transfer of the archive from Arizona
to New York.
I was in charge of packing and then unpacking
the 500,000 pieces of paper that constitute
the archive.
Once we were familiar with looking at more
of the drawings and having a couple
that we knew were by Wright's hands you could
begin to understand how he did draw and the
quality of his hand.
You know, he's such a larger-than-life figure
to everyone and you kind of expect these vast,
sort of you know drawings of great vigor or
enthusiasm but in fact he's quite delicate
and sort of more, sort of working his way
through all of the details and he does a lot
of writing.
His handwriting is actually rather small.
It's not bold or vigorous so it's easier to
tell him within that.
And even looking at the other drawings you
can often see his comments throughout the
working drawings as he's approving and making
suggestions of how to improve certain projects.
The studio itself developed a capacity to
do their own renderings and the major person
behind that early part is Marion Mahony, who
was a woman who was from Evanston originally.
She went to MIT and became one of the first
graduates of, female graduates of an architecture
school in the United States and she was a
licensed architect as well.
She was considered the great graphic hand
within his studio.
And she is the early sort of proponent that
sets their drawings in this very aesthetic
way.
This seems to have been very important to
Wright that he had an aesthetic image for
the drawings not just a kind of pedestrian
working drawings with you know, renderings
that were pretty pictures he had such an aesthetic
interest in all the arts, in Japanese prints,
in graphic arts in general.
And it's in her image of this with Wright's
annotations and adaptations and corrections
that the work goes towards, and the sort of
summation of this material is in the Wasmuth
Portfolio, the great summary of Wright's early
career that he went to Europe and published
in 1910.
And for me this is a representative set, these
three drawings here because it encapsulates
the process of the studio with the major people
involved in the projects.
You have the drawing here of the Rogers Lacy
Hotel, its conceptual drawing by Frank Lloyd
Wright all the details, all the floors, all
the heights, the module of the building.
He's even added a couple of perspectives of
how he views the tower will look and then
he's actually reworked it so often that there
are, is a cut-out in the middle.
He had to extend the paper several times because
the building just kept getting bigger and
so it's really a work in progress.
And then when you look at-- and look at the
oral histories of the people involved the
perspective was done by Jack Howe who was
the head of the drafting room in the Taliesin
Studios from about 1933 until 1959 when Wright
died.
And this perspective according to Howe's oral
history was completely done by him, that Wright
never put a pencil to it, so you get the pure
version of what the head drafting person would
have done with a perspective drawing.
What you see on the table is just a fraction,
a tiny fraction of the range of what's actually
in the archive itself.
There is close to half a million pieces of
paper that document the creative genius of
Frank Lloyd Wright.